bonjour bruno bartocetti merci de
répondre à nos questions tôt ce matin
sur rtl france six unités de forces
mobiles devraient notamment être
déployés pour sécuriser et sécuriser les
champs-elysées est ce qu'il faut
craindre des débordements à quoi faut-il
s'attendre exactement cet après midi oui
bon je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
oui on craint toujours des débordements
parce que nous avons des manifestations
déclarées d'autres qui seront très
certainement sauvage et si vous voulez
ce qui est important de retenir c'est
que dans le monde sait en france où on
enregistre le plus de manifestations on
en enregistre tous les jours ça se passe
toujours très bien mais malgré tout même
si on peut s'attendre à deux cent mille
manifestants dans le france environ
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que ces
manifestations vont être infiltré par
des troubles fêtes
j'avais deux tirs par des casseurs et
c'est là où on doit très très vigilants
notamment notamment en fin de semaine de
portage en fin de manifestation donc
c'est vrai convient thomas sont montrés
très vigilant et puis voilà on pensait
déjà à la rentrée sociale du mois de
septembre ou si c'est manifestation
perdure on risque de rencontrer encore
un peu plus de débordements et c'est là
où il va falloir être encore plus
vigilants vous parlez la rentrée sociale
de la rentrée sociale de septembre
justement 114 1161 1200 4000
manifestants la semaine dernière le
nombre de manifestants va crescendo 1 2
samedi en samedi alors qu on est en été
et que ce sont les vacances à la rentrée
en septembre justement à quoi s'attendre
voilà nous nous le sushi chinois s'est
pas tellement le nombre de manifestants
ça peut sauver triplé à partir du moment
où toute façon à la liberté de
manifester en france un portable à
partir du moment où les manifestants se
font entendre de par le nombre de pas
leur voix il n'y a aucune raison qu'il y
ait de soucis nous ce qu'est ce qui est
gênant ce qui est très
contraria pour pourvu policiers c'est
lorsqu'on a un rituel de manifestations
à dire tous les samedis le même rituel
sans encadrement sans parfois sans sa
liberté de manifester parce qu'il ya des
endroits où on ne peut pas manifester on
c'est interdit et bien c'est là où
malheureusement ancrée que des voyous
les chiffres ces cortèges pour casser et
lorsqu'on parle de casse on pense à vous
journalistes puisque vous est pris à
partie aussi quand vous êtes au milieu
de ces manifestations
on pense aux commerçants il n'y a pas
que les policiers qui sont pris pour
cible et c'est ça notre crainte c'est
pas tellement le nombre de manifestants
s'est surtout les la minorité de
casseurs qui enregistre ces
manifestations notamment les black
blocks le fait-elle conseil
constitutionnel a validé l'essentiel de
la loi anti qu'ovide il ya deux jours
est ce que c'est un peu en à redire les
manifestants et les casseurs que vous
citez ce que cela peut les pousser à
être plus virulent encore oui on peut on
peut le penser même si il va y avoir un
essoufflement on va dire dans l'esprit à
partir du moment où le texte a été signé
ça va être ça va être compliqué pour
prolos contesté puisqu'il est puisqu'il
va être appliquée mais c'est vrai que ça
va ça va rebooster ses black bloc on
sait où ces casseurs il ya une reprise
aux politiques qui risquent d'être faite
derrière qui ceci alors je ne peux pas
du doigt les politiques nous permettant
d viola mais ça risque de donner
peut-être deux de la force ceux qui sont
mal intentionnées et c'est vrai concret
n'en crée de ça déborde si ce rituel se
met en place à tous les samedis comme on
l'a vu avec des gilets jaunes natation
qui ait pas de malentendu on cible pas
les gilet jaune encore une fois aussi de
ceux qui auraient filtré ces mouvements
on a peur de retrouver le même mouvement
de casseurs au milieu de ces
manifestations
bruno bartocetti je me permets de
revenir sur le détail du dispositif
policier parisien 1560 crs et gendarmes
mobiles 150 policiers dans les
transports dès ce matin 8 brigade de
répression de l'action
violente les braves 3000 policiers donc
en tout on l'a dit alors qu'on attend
dix mille manifestants
est-ce que c'est pas un peu démesuré ce
que ça risque pas de provoquer et de
créer une tension anxyogène dès le début
de la manifestation surtout que le
renseignement territoriale aurait prévu
des manifestations a priori je cite
bonne enfant oui alors c'est un fait si
vous voulez ce qui est important c'est
d'aller manifestation lorsque les
encadrent c'est la proximité qui peut y
avoir entre les policiers et les
manifestants dont l'intéressé ne sera
pas d'être on va dire visible dans un
premier temps mais d'être proche pour
intervenir en cas de débordements
donc tout ce n'est pas tellement le nom
mais s'arrête sur le dispositif est
l'endroit où on va se situer j'ai peur
que ça a été bien réfléchi parce que
l'on parle des braves le point
d'intervenir si malheureusement le doit
de le faire
en fait deux en fin de journée donc
elles seront le seront plus discrètes on
va dire dans un premier temps sur ces
manifestations la préfecture de police
demande aux agents mobilisés d'éviter
les gaz lacrymogènes pour ne pas avoir
de mauvaise image
comment intervenir alors sachant qu'en
plus de ça la clé d'étranglement et
maintenant internet aussi ce sera le
lbbc ça oui ça peut être le bd mais les
bombes de désencerclement peuvent être
le 10 utilisent également ces pour
écarter on va dire les manifestants et
neutraliser décidé les casseurs qui eux
sont équipés pour justement nous
affronter alors on sait aussi dans notre
pays qu'à partir du moment où on utilise
des outils de défense et on est bien
d'accord
et bien c'est considérer comme des
outils d'attac alors que ce n'est pas le
cas on est là pour protéger pour se
défendre et écarter les manifestants des
casseurs comment l'interprétez tout ceci
il écouté la lecture elle se fait
associé également par une
on va dire malheureusement par une une
protection politique c'est à dire qu'en
france on demande aux gendarmes et aux
policiers d'intervenir avec le minimum
de matériel on se rend compte
je crois qu'à un moment donné on n'est
pas sur la planète bisounours en face de
nous nous avons des personnes qui sont
déterminés qui ont dit qu'ils sont
porteurs d'armes par destination ou de
pouvoir bien sûr intervenir rapidement
pour pouvoir se protéger protéger mes
jeux
un puissant outil pour pour manifester
donc pas ce nom pas se prendre des coups
et et cassé des vitrines donc c'est vrai
que c'est difficile ce rendement de nos
policiers aujourd'hui c'est d'intervenir
mais avec moins de moyens
vous êtes policier un dans le sud on a
beaucoup parlé de paris il ya 150 vilain
qui sont concernés par des
manifestations cet après-midi en
occitanie en paca vous vous êtes à
montpellier à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre la même chose qu'à paris des
débordements également il ya des villes
qui sont plus à même de voir des heures
que d'autres oui alors là pour leur jeu
mais difficile de cibler neuville c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de villes qui
sont concernés par cette manifestation
on a eu l'exemple de montpellier pendant
est analysé les jeunes tous les samedi
nous avions des blessés parmi les forces
de l'ordre de la casse voilà je connais
bien cette ville de montpellier mais on
peut s'attendre à des débordements dans
les grandes villes de de la zone sud qui
rappelle que ces occitanie paca et corse
mais on voit là on peut considérer que
des villes comme toulouse marseille et
montpellier peuvent être des tripes pour
pour pour cible par à part ces casseurs
qui et qui est même filtrer ces
mouvements là parce qu'ils sont nombreux
dans ces grandes villes mais pour
l'heure ce sam est difficile d'anticiper
de vous dire à quel endroit il va y
avoir des débordements on reste très
très vigilant mais très très présent
justement pour les stars de paris de
protéger les citoyennes les commerçants
même et bien sûr les journalistes qui
sont pris pour cible en france pour ma
part tout comme à paris excusez moi pour
le pour le merci merci beaucoup bruno
bartocetti d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire zone sud sgp police fo
merci